what does the future hold for women in
afghanistan
some have been taken to the streets to
protest against the violation of their
rights but the taliban have already
begun restricting their freedom and many
fear the worst is yet to come
it's absurd everything has stopped for
us many people have left i feel lonely
and desperate
as the taliban start to make their mark
on women's lives you'll also hear from a
former afghan government minister who
tells us where she thinks the
international community is going wrong
in its dealings with the country and its
new rulers
[Music]
welcome to dw news asia glad you could
join us
life is changing for many people in
afghanistan for women the prospects are
looking especially bleak the taliban
seems poised to impose what critics are
calling a very regressive version of
sharia law radically restricting women's
freedoms they're already making moves to
banish women from public life telling
them to stay inside and threatening them
at demonstrations
significantly they have failed to
include a single woman in their new
interim government despite women being
part of the previous administration and
despite promises to be inclusive in a
moment we'll hear from a former female
member of the afghan cabinet but first
this report on how life for women
appears to be shaping up under taliban
rule
it takes courage to protest openly
against the taliban especially for women
yet these female protesters in mazay
sharif refuse to be silenced
we demand the creation of secure jobs
both for men and women and the right to
participate in politics for women
the right for women to be selected and
elected for leadership positions and the
right to private ownership
the right for women to work in the
judicial and legal sector and the right
to freedom of speech
but the taliban's strict gender rules
have already started to affect everyday
life
female students returning to university
on the first day of lectures after the
summer break
found they'd been separated from their
male classmates
before we all studied together we were
comrades
and now this curtain
it's horrible but we have no choice
it's absurd everything has stopped for
us many people have left i feel lonely
and desperate
when the taliban ruled afghanistan 20
years ago women's rights were severely
curtailed
women were not allowed to work they were
banned from education and only allowed
in public fully covered and accompanied
by a male chaperone
this time around the hardline islamists
have been keen to portray themselves as
more moderate
in their first press conference after
taking power their spokesman promised
women's rights would be honored within
the norms of islamic law
though he failed to elaborate on what
exactly this would mean
many women in afghanistan expect to
return to the dark days of the taliban's
first reign
we spoke to a student at the american
university of afghanistan in kabul
you know like when
when someone is
dreaming for for a better life and
working for 21 years to to
to just reach the dream and suddenly in
one night everything just damaged
just imagine
and now i i might still feel like i'm in
a room where
only there is a darkness
no hope for a better future or no hope
for a lot
this is the feeling that i really have
that feeling of hopelessness is far from
unwarranted
two weeks ago the taliban told working
women to stay at home for security
reasons
a measure they said was temporary
but many fear this is just one of many
steps towards a society in which women
will ultimately be deprived of their
fundamental rights and freedoms
and all but erased from public life
and one woman who was a part of
afghanistan's public life till she had
to leave the country is nargis nehan she
served as minister of mines and
petroleum and joins me now from oslo ms
nihan welcome not one woman in the
taliban government that's been announced
how does that make you feel
uh to be honest you're not surprised but
deeply disappointed because this is what
we have been telling everybody that
taliban uh on the contrary what their
leaderships are saying in doha
they have not changed a lot they have
not evolved a lot
while as a society working for
women inclusion and inclusivity of our
society and the political process of
country we have been advocating and we
have been giving definition of inclusive
that inclusive should not even be
limited to
ethnical uh
representatives but also representative
from different gender from different
religious groups from different uh
part of the society from different
ideology but what we see that according
to that definition you cannot call
the
new cabinet
formed by the taliban
in any way an inclusive
cabinet
speaking of the rights of women now the
taliban have repeatedly said that women
will have rights under sharia law i
wonder
if you
understand what the taliban mean by
women's rights under sharia law
still that is uh we are also waiting for
the taliban to um
in terms of their policy to articulate
more but on the ground what we see in
the last few uh weeks the tall one has
taken charge i see i give three examples
which alarms me uh that taliban are
going to implement once again the very
regressive version of sharia that they
have uh interpreted themselves last time
so women went peacefully for
demonstration because most of them are
working in public offices and most of
them are responsible for us as
breadwinner of their family but alban
began to shoot at them
secondly what we saw the taliban
yesterday announced their cabinet
all you see it's uh
all mullahs
from the taliban
group inclusive government but you don't
find any other group and any uh other
gender
of the society included in their in
their cabinet and thirdly the ministry
of uh higher education of islamic
emirate came up with a policy for the
private and public universities to
reopen but we saw that they came with
very restrictive policy that there
should be parda if the classes are have
fewer students and if they have enough
student they should definitely go for
separate classes there should be
separate interest formats women separate
waiting room so already these three
examples of telling us a lot about you
like how much they have changed and how
much they have not changed
but aren't the taliban articulating what
is already common practice in many of
afghanistan's rural areas where even
before the taliban didn't took over
women couldn't go to work and girls
couldn't go to school
the point is that i
there are some districts of afghanistan
that still
people do not have access
to
to schools and uh there are some
generations some women in afghanistan
that essentially they choose to be at
home but that doesn't mean that you
deprive all women of afghanistan because
just you assume that a group of a small
group of the society do not want that
that is what a diverse and inclusive
society means that you have to as a
government and uh trying to govern a
govern a nation you have to look at the
aspiration and demand of all population
and try to respond to that not to the
ones that actually resonate with your
ideology
right i'd also like to discuss with you
what the international community feels
about the taliban's promises of
inclusivity and therefore at this point
i'd like to play for our viewers what
the eu's ambassador and head of the eu
delegation to afghanistan said on monday
in brussels about women's rights under
the taliban
there's no need for alarmism in a way
because all what's happening is embedded
in in in the society afghanistan and
sometimes alarmism
when it's a single focus that prevents
us from from looking at the entire
problems what i meant by no alarmism is
to treat a political actor not by what
uh
the entity has said 25 years ago but to
look at what is happening now right
now you just heard andreas brandt there
do you think people are being alarmist
about the future of women for women
under the taliban
uh well i think because many people even
living outside afghanistan they are much
more aware of
afghanistan new afghanistan aspiration
of the new generation and about the
tactics the taliban have been using as a
political group um
that's why of course they're alarmed
i mean i don't know when uh ambassador
andrea uh made these statements but as i
told you look at the cabinet that gives
you uh that clearly tell you what the
taliban are thinking
look at the reaction to the money of
hundreds of women that they came out
for a peaceful demonstration and look at
their policy for the higher education um
the problem that we have is that on one
hand turbo leadership is promising one
thing they're beginning to deliver
totally uh on the contrary different
thing
and then in the meantime this is
something that we have been trying for
for years to the international community
that you cannot just simple believe in
the taliban or in other
politicians that we have previously
based on what they tell you and what
they promised you with those nice words
that they said in the meetings you have
to look at the reality on the ground
that's what's happening and what is
happening in afghanistan
it might be a very small part of this
part of society embedded in afghanistan
but the difficulty cannot represent the
majority and overall afghanistan
uh briefly ms nihan do you think the
international community has any leverage
at all over the taliban to make them
follow their promises
the
international community had a lot of
leverage unfortunately they misused they
didn't use it properly still the
international community has a lot of
leverage what i see is lack of
consistency and international community
lack of coordination and uh and
basically lack of seriousness about
issues of afghanistan uh they still do
not have you know united stand with
regard to dealing with the taliban and
everybody once again is rushing and
trying to advocate for the taliban and
you're trying to fight build their own
relation with the taliban without
thinking about the consequence of that
and overall
all the policies that you want to pursue
with the taliban
narcissist we'll have to leave it there
for the time being but thank you so much
for joining us today
thank you
and women in the country have been
making their presence felt at street
protests yesterday and today in
different parts of the country we'll
leave you with some of those images and
see you tomorrow bye
[Music]
[Music]
you